Мене звати Оксана, мені 31 рік. Я живу в Москві,
працюю в модній компанії піарницею.
І я виїжджаю з Росії до Німеччини.
Москва для мене, мабуть, найкраще місто в Росії, з яких можна вибрати.
Однак це некомфортне для мене місто, бо в ньому
дуже багато машин, дуже багато людей і дуже мало
особистого простору. Плюс дуже важливий момент для мене був,
який мотивував, це моя робота.
Тобто моя зарплатня в євро за 10 років практично не змінилася,
хоча в рублях вона, можливо, втричі збільшилася.
Народжувати дітей тут я не хочу, абсолютно,
на 100 відсотків. Купувати квартиру - це нереально.
Мене звати Анастасія Володіна, мені 19 років.
Я навчаюся на мультиплікатора і
я хочу поїхати з Росії.
Хочу поїхати до Чехії на кілька років на навчання,
тому що там безкоштовна освіта. І я думаю,
швидше за все, до тебе там будуть ставитися
як до людини - по-доброму, з повагою і враховуючи
твій смак, враховуючи твій стиль, не намагаючись
тебе якимось чином змінити. Якщо я приїду,
наприклад, зараз до свого викладача з тим,
що я намалювала в новій техніці, ось подивіться,
наприклад, я намалювала в пастелі.
Він скаже: що це за жах, ні, мені це не подобається.
В усьому, що стосується соціальної політики -
і економічної, і політичної - або стоїмо на місці,
або котимося назад. Ну, мабуть,
найсильнішим показником був черговий термін Путіна.
Не те щоб ми на щось сподівались інше, однак це
якось сильно розкрило очі. І жодних змін у майбутньому я вже тут не бачу.
У мене там буде європейський університет, який
цінуватимуть в усьому світі, не лише в Росії.
Ну тому що в них інший менталітет, інші стандарти освіти.
Всі ці мінуси пригнічують твою особистість,
твою свободу. І через це багато людей виїжджають.
Ми вже на фінішній прямій.
Подаємося на національну візу, розпродаємо нашу скромну власність.
У принципі, вже готові розпочати там усе з нуля.
Я очікую саме стабільності і впевненості в завтрашньому дні,
тому що я зможу нормально взяти кредит.
Якщо я захочу розпочати свій малий бізнес,
мені не треба за нього боятися. Я просто хочу
бути впевненою в тому, що на мої права більше ніхто не зазіхатиме
і мене залишать у спокої.
У Європі я зможу вийти за рамки,
зможу якось перебороти себе в плані творчості,
спробувати різні стилі, різні техніки.
І не буде ось цього засудження збоку.
Насправді багато хто хоче чогось більшого і кращого
і не бачить тут перспектив розвиватися в творчому плані - це точно.